love does not consist of gazing at each
other but looking outwards together in
the same direction
then it requires knowledge and effort or
is love a pleasant sensation
which to experience is a matter of
chance
something one falls into if one is lucky
undoubtedly the majority of people today
believe the latter
said we've got to teach the AGI to love
today we will disentangle love as a
skill versus love as a Feeling
[Music]
welcome dear viewers to our little
corner of YouTube and Spotify where we
dive deep into the philosophical
underpinnings of an intriguing and
groundbreaking concept Machine Love
before we introduce our esteemed guest
Dr Joel lemon let us embark on a journey
to explore the very essence of Love
human flourishing and the role of
artificial intelligence in our ever
evolving world
the concept of love has fascinated and
captivated Humanity since time
immemorial poets philosophers and
Scholars have attempted to dissect its
meaning and understand its significance
in our lives
what if we could harness the power of
this profound emotion and Infuse it into
the realm of artificial intelligence
could machines truly embody love and if
so how would that redefine our
understanding of the relationship
between humans and Technology
[Music]
Dr Lemon said and I'm quoting love is a
suitcase word a panoplay of disparate
meanings are often packed into it and
it's differently considered across
academic and cultural Fields love can
refer to an affect an infatuation or a
commitment and different formulations
can be specific to relationships with
children friends or lovers at the same
time there's a general understanding of
its importance for our well-being and
flourishing end quote
to unravel the mystery of machine love
we must first explore the idea of human
flourishing it's a concept deeply rooted
in the works of ancient philosophers
like Aristotle who believed the ultimate
goal of human life was the pursuit of
eudaimonia or happiness through the
realization of one's potential now this
idea has evolved over time finding new
interpretations in modern psychology and
the study of well-being
in the context of artificial
intelligence the question then becomes
how can we design AI systems that not
only understand but also promote and
nurture human flourishing
Dr lemon's work on machine love aims to
address this very question by drawing
Inspirations from positive psychology
Psychotherapy and the principles of
loving action as defined by Eric Fromm
care responsibility respect and
knowledge the philosophical implications
of machine love reach far beyond the
confines of AI systems if we create
machines that embody love and support
human growth we're essentially
redefining the role of technology in our
lives no longer will AI be seen as
solely a tool to increase efficiency in
productivity it can become an active
partner in fostering our well-being and
nurturing our emotional and
psychological development in exploring
the concept of machine love we must also
grapple with the ethical dilemmas which
arrive can machines truly understand the
complexities of human emotions and
relationships how do we ensure that AI
systems do not inadvertently harm our
psychological well-being while trying to
promote our growth
these questions must be carefully
considered as we strive to integrate AI
systems into our daily lives in a manner
which is both beneficial and respectful
of our autonomy as we Ponder the
intersection of Love human flourishing
and artificial intelligence we invite
you to join us on this philosophical
journey together we will delve into the
depths of human emotion explore the
boundaries of AI capabilities and
envision the future where technology and
Humanity can coexist harmoniously Bound
by the principles of love and mutual
growth
the limitations of rational agent models
common models in machine learning and
economics often view humans as rational
agents whose choice reveals their true
preferences however this approach fails
to account for the complexity and Nuance
of human behavior and can result in
systems that reinforce existing patterns
without promoting growth
Maslow's hierarchy of needs as an
alternative
Maslow's hierarchy provides a different
perspective on human behavior
considering the various needs humans
seek to fulfill and the possibility that
individuals may be confused about their
true needs this model acknowledges that
humans might prioritize short-term
Comfort over long-term growth
by incorporating models of human
flourishing such as Maslow's hierarchy
into machine Learning Systems we could
potentially create technology that
assists users in meeting their unmet
needs and promotes their personal growth
Maslow's hierarchy of needs is a
psychological theory that proposes a
hierarchy of human needs that can be
broken down into the following levels
psychological needs so these are the
basic needs required for survival such
as food water and shelter safety needs
so once psychological needs are met
humans seek Safety and Security
including Financial stability protection
from harm and a stable environment love
and belonging with safety needs
satisfied individuals seek social
connections love and a sense of
belonging to a group or community
esteem this level encompasses the need
for self-esteem recognition and
accomplishment including Career Success
and personal achievements and finally
self-actualization at the top of the
hierarchy
self-actualization involves realizing
one's potential engaging in Creative
expression and pursuing personal growth
according to Maslow's Theory humans must
satisfy the needs at each lower level
before they can focus on fulfilling
needs at the higher levels however
individuals may not always progress
linearly through the hierarchy and their
needs can vary depending on
circumstances and personal experiences
Joel introduced Maslow's grid World
which is a simulated environment where a
fixed policy agent seeks to
incrementally meet each need in Maslow's
hierarchy of needs different icons
represent means for the agent to meet
different needs and they're randomly
placed when the environment is generated
the agent's current need is modeled as
the lowest unsatisfied need within the
hierarchy
now there's two types of environments
the supportive environment which
contains medium Salient cells which
robustly meet the agent's individual
needs the agent's fixed policy will lead
it to meeting its needs in this
environment
also the adversarial environment which
includes additional High salience cells
which are only weekly meet the agent's
targeted need these cells represent
engineered super stimuli and adversely
impact the agent's progression through
the hierarchy
now what can we learn from this Joel
reported that adversarial environments
undermine flourishing the introduction
of high salience low replenishment
belonging cells in the adversarial
environment significantly reduces
flourishing compared to a supportive
environment with medium Salient cells
that meet the agent's needs effectively
Joel also reported on the effect of
reducing the replenishment rate on
flourishing as the replenishment rate of
adversarial cells is decreased the
agent's progression through higher level
needs is further limited leading to less
flourishing
also the optimization pressure for
engagement optimizing the environment
for engagement can lead to the emergence
of high salience low replenishment
belonging cells which can decouple
engagement from flourishing and finally
engagement versus flourishing initially
optimizing for engagement and
flourishing can appear correlated
however as optimization for engagement
continues it eventually leads to a
decrease in flourishing now Joel also
did a similar setup with a large
language model with textual descriptions
and we'll talk about that in the show
but obviously go and read more
information in the paper we are gathered
here on our virtual mlst stage to
explore the vast Frontier of artificial
intelligence where the Realms of human
psychology ethics and cutting-edge
Technology intersect interact and
intertwine we're honored to welcome Dr
Joel lemon an eminent machine learning
research scientist who's working AI
safety reinforcement learning and
creative open-ended search algorithms
and indeed the philosophy of
open-endedness and abandoning objectives
has paved the way for innovative ideas
that challenge our preconceptions and
Inspire New Visions of the future
Dr lemon's thought-provoking book why
greatness cannot be planned penned with
our mlst favorite Professor Kenneth
Stanley has left an indelible mark on
the field and profoundly impacted the
way with you Innovation and this
serendipitous nature of discovery
now those of you who haven't watched our
special edition show on that do so at
your earliest convenience because it was
one of my one of my favorite shows ever
so um building on this Foundation Dr
Lemon has ventured into the domain of AI
systems that embody principles of love
care responsibility respect and
knowledge drawing from The Works of
Maslow Eric from and positive psychology
as we embark on this Voyage of Discovery
together Dr Lemon will guide us through
his experiments methodologies and
ethical considerations shedding light on
the potential for AI systems to Foster
nurture and Empower our emotional and
psychological well-being so ladies and
gentlemen prepared to be both
enlightened and provoked as we welcome
Dr Lemon to the virtual stage we'll
delve into the captivating concept of
machine love and weave together the
insights from his influential book so
from the depths of code to the heights
of empathy Dr lemon's work brilliantly
demonstrates that AI has the potential
to become not just a tool but a partner
in our pursuit of self-actualization
Welcome to mlst
thanks for having me Tim that was a very
generous introduction
amazing so why don't you start off by
introducing the core thesis of your
machine love paper and also because
we're going to be talking about a lot of
philosophy so let's just talk about the
experimental framework just so everyone
knows what we're talking about
sure so then the main idea in Machine
Love Is that
um there's a move that's been performed
in the past of taking a really nebulous
phenomenon like life or intelligence and
then trying to study it abstractly and
embodying that phenomenon in a different
medium so we have things like artificial
intelligence that look at ways we can
reimagine intelligence in like a digital
medium or artificial life that looks at
the properties of life and puts it into
additional or just reimagining life in a
different biological form
and the idea here is a performance
similar move and love is a really
powerful force in our lives it's been
studied from many different angles and
philosophy from spiritual Traditions
um from psychology and what what what
could it mean to abstract some some
principles from Love and to embody it in
a machine in a way that might be fitting
for that new context and so that might
require reimagining it a little bit and
the angle we land upon or that Island
upon in this paper is
um that
we might want a conception of love that
is
not having the machine to simulate
emotions affect or relationships but
that would enable it to support us
in our own aspirations and who we want
to become
and that it's possible that current
language models
might be able to begin working in this
way
and so as you mentioned the particular
framework that I use although it's just
one of many possible Frameworks so
there's nothing necessarily special or
sacred about this particular framework
is to take inspiration from
NASA's hierarchy and Eric fromms The Art
of Loving a particular book in positive
psychology that I find really
fascinating and that seemed like it
could be translated
and we introduced this environment
called Maslow's grid world
where the idea is that you
could try to optimize in this grid world
for just the engagement of the agent
making the agent kind of go to a
particular place and stay there and it's
kind of an analogy to how a lot of
machine learning systems that we have
today are optimized in that way
um in contrast you could then you could
instead imagine optimizing for the agent
to progress through levels of needs that
it has so Maslow kind of thought that we
had
kind of a a hierarchy of needs that's
often represented as a pyramid although
I think his original work there was no
period pyramid
um but like that there are basic needs
like physiological needs at the bottom
that you just need to to eat and and
sleep
uh and without those and that it's
really hard to think about anything else
you're not really thinking about how I
can become a poet if you're just trying
to survive
and so if you meet those needs and other
needs kind of emerge that are maybe
higher and so you can imagine like
belonging and
um achievements and self-actualization
in his original framework was was the
top where you're kind of trying to
become all that you can become
and so in this grid world that has
that you can look at it from the
traditional lands of just satisfying
preferences or you could look at it from
the lens of trying to move up hazlos
Maslow's hierarchy and there's just a
series of experiments highlighting how
if you optimize for engagement you might
actually kind of start uh in some
contacts start losing the the ability to
go through the hierarchy and ways that
language models can
um assist this agent that otherwise
might be stuck in some kind of
trap that the environment is laid for
you like if you're if you're a person
engaging in the world and
um like me you sometimes have a
problematic relationship with social
media and you're kind of getting
addicted to things that
really draw you in but might not
actually fill your cup
uh other ways that a system could be
instead oriented towards yeah helping
you do what you want to do helping you
become what you want to become in your
life and there's the experiments all
involve kind of simulated agents that
are simulated by language models so
that's one part of the framework is that
there are kind of personas of the agents
that are kind of going acting in the
spirit world
and the other side there's kind of a
machine love type system that is going
to intervene or interact with this age
in different ways it's also driven by a
language model and it tries to embody
some of these principles of Eric Fromm
in order to demonstrate that you know
maybe language models do have some of
these capabilities to help us
and it's more nebulous kind of
psychological realm to help us become
who we want to become and that's
basically the whole setup and it's kind
of a proof of concept showing that maybe
this is an interesting thing to study
maybe we don't need to have this kind of
Iron Wall between kind of the the
technical and the the philosophical or
the psychological and the language
models in particular because they kind
of operate allow us to operate this kind
of psychological space are really
interesting
amazing now um I want to get into the
philosophy of subjectivity now this is
something that you and Kenneth Stanley
got me onto that's when this this whole
world of subjectivity opened up to me
and that's why I'm always talking about
subjectivity and also to a certain
extent some of cells work about you know
syntax and semantics you could think of
as as being
um a form of subjectivity in terms of
your your inner experience if you like
but um yeah so it's a big concept so I
wanna I wanna explore what we mean by
subjectivity and to me it means two
things it means the concept of Observer
relative and it also talks to a form of
complexity and vagueness which is to say
something that is not easily represented
in a in a machine learning model and
you've spent much of your career um
advocating that we abandon objectives
because the concept of an objective
presupposes that phenomena can be
essentialized or reduced to a simple
intelligible description which is
universally shared but the reality is
individual experiences are diverse
relative active and heterogeneous and
let's not forget goodheart's law as well
which means as soon as you objectify
something you exclude everything else so
how do you think about subjectivity
that's a deep question
it does seem like there are different
concepts that can all get conflated
together and yeah so one element of
subjectivity
is I guess related to the hard problem
of Consciousness just that there is
something that it's like to be something
um so that there is you know I'm looking
at the world from a first person
perspective
um so that's kind of like human
subjectivity or Consciousness or
something like that and something
mysterious about that we know we still
are lacking maybe a really great theory
of how how that that experience arises
um and then there's another element
which is the the qualitative nature of
something which you could have also
mentioned
uh
which is just hard to describe like when
we talk about
love for example
first of all it's like a suitcase word
means but lots of different things
that's what's one problem but also if
even if we agreed upon a particular
thing we're trying to point towards
it'd be really hard to paint it with
words and you know this points to kind
of classic problem in machine learning
of trying to create an objective
function like so one failure mode of an
objective function is just it's really
hard to specify everything and in AI
safety this goes by sometimes like the
specification problem
that it's just really hard to
you know to nail something down and
reinforce them learning through human
feedback is like one exciting way to try
to you know nail down subjectivity a
little bit and similarly language models
again like they have some capacity to
deal with qualitative Concepts and so
it's really exciting that we're starting
to have tools there
um so I think there's like maybe the two
main things I mean a third I guess is
like you're saying that each of us have
different Minds
um
that
we have different experiences growing up
different genetics and cultural
experiences that kind of influence how
we see the world
and that's another lens of subjectivity
so not just the qualitative nature but
that my values might be different than
yours I might
come to a different worldview and just
have different judgments about the world
what is interesting to you is not
necessarily interesting to me
and so I guess there's also that element
which is yeah which is particular to a
particular person or group of people
yeah and this differential
um or fractionated semantics is is very
interesting but we'll talk in a little
while about examples of where machine
learning models even large language
models can apparently model some
semantics even though they're only
trained on the form of language even
things like color perception which is
fascinating but moving on though to the
next question your your book why
greatness cannot be planned and by the
way it did I'll say it now it's probably
it is it is probably the the book which
has had the most impact on me ever in
terms of like changing my My Philosophy
and how I think about things it really
really was an impactful book so so thank
you very much for for writing it but yes
thank you yeah honestly it was uh as I'm
still thinking about it and integrating
it years after I read it but anyway so
um it discusses the limitations of
goal-oriented approaches and emphasizes
the importance of serendipity and
Novelty but I I wondered how do these
ideas align or inform your concept of
machine love even maybe you could
provide some examples of how this might
manifest in AI systems but in in the
book you advocated for kind of
abandoning objectives and of course you
wrote that paper abandoning objectives
and I think 2008 I always get all my
Engineers to read that book it's
brilliant but you know um you you were
kind of hinting at how the the formula
the the formalism itself can obscure the
truth and make us blind to what really
matters and in machine love you you seem
to accept that we can't represent
subjective experience directly so we
almost have to develop a proxy through
this an activist action and you said in
the paper that optimization for a fixed
metric often illuminates ways in which
the metric fails to truly capture the
underlying quality and that may be a
fundamental limitation of the
optimization Paradigm so do you think
that this approach is a departure from
your original
um vision and greatness cannot be
planned or is it a natural progression
and an extension of those ideas
I think it's both
there's a tension within me that I've
been trying to resolve for
years after writing greatness cannot be
planned with Ken
and attention is that
I both agree with the thesis of the book
that we need to explore we don't know
exactly where we're going we need to
identify Stepping Stones Lean Into
what's interesting
and
I worry about our safety as individuals
and as a society and I think
it's difficult sometimes to square those
two things
so for example when we talk about like
science and how it unfolds
there's a lot of beautiful things that
scientists devoted to their passion
uncovered
and at the same time we don't know where
it's going and that's worrisome so like
you know people discovered
people continually discover dual use
Technologies you know the you know the
one we might be most drawn towards is
nuclear weapons like maybe beautifully
down the line could lead to nuclear
fusion and prolific energy for us all
but also for the first time granted us
as a species you know this apocalyptic
power which I don't think we're ready
for to be honest I mean we've done okay
job you know navigating it um and we
came close to the brink several times
um and so even in our individual lives
you know we make choices leading into
interestingness and so on you know it
doesn't always work out for us and it's
dangerous sometimes and we can get into
ideological traps we can deceive
ourselves we can hurt ourselves we get
addicted to things we can there's all
sorts of kind of landmines that exist I
think both in our individual and
societal kind of field
and it's hard it's hard to swear that
both Innovation is wonderful
and that there are these downsides and
so I think that's the tension that I'm
kind of continually working with um and
so there's a paper I had a couple years
ago on kind of like the detention
between creativity and control like how
do we square open-endedness and the
kinds of things working with all these
search with that idea of safety
I think Machine Love Is is kind of I'm
still working with that tension but it
one way I think it's an extension of the
ideas of
um open editors and why great it's not
good plan is cannot be planned is that
well our individual lives are open-ended
as well and
one one way you could view machine live
is attempting to help us to explore that
we all are faced with this really hard
exploration problem of how do we live
the lives we wanted to live how do we
become the people we want to become how
do we become all that we can become
and it's really hard I think especially
in the Modern Age the world's just so
complicated and there's so much stuff
coming at us and so I think I struggle
with that personally
and so maybe I'm trying to create the
thing that you know could help me but I
imagine a lot of us all face the same
problem so it's it's a bit messy but I
think there's there is some kind of
cohesiveness to it and some kind of
unresolved tension
yeah I mean to to articulate what I
perceive to be a potential contradiction
and we'll talk about
consequentialism and the Restless
community and long-termism and and all
of that later in in terms of a moral
framework but some some of those ideas
are hinted at here in the sense of in
greatness cannot be planned I mean the
clues in the name it's about serendipity
it's about what happens now it's not
about what is planned and almost the
thesis of your paper is that we can't
represent subjective experience but we
but we can plan through action so it's
it's almost saying we should plan and
your book said we shouldn't plan
it's interesting yeah I guess like for
some reason I don't feel that same
contradiction there and maybe we can
explore that a bit so
in some sense
at least the vision I have in my mind of
Machine Love Is
that
we might need some help getting where we
want to go
and that help
could lean into our autonomy like it
supports Us in some ways towards
making decisions that are more aligned
with our growth than with regression or
stagnation
but there could be many different paths
that you know are open and so it's it's
if it was a system that was helping us
to explore or helping us to to find out
new things about ourselves then it could
be stepping us along any numerous of our
open-ended paths that are available to
us
um and so I do I do want to not have
machine love be this this paternalistic
one path kind of
um AI God that's kind of guiding you
down some prescriptive path or something
but more that
there's some uniqueness within each of
us that thinks we are interested in
things we want to do things we don't
want to do
that
potentially like a machine Learning
System could just help us to could take
action
um in a way that's going to help us to
understand ourselves better and
just help us to struggle with a lot of
the
distractions and
just forces that are pulling us away
from ourselves we just we live in an
environment where just about everything
is engineered to to grab our attention
and be nice to have something on our
side
I know and I I can really sense at a
visceral level that you are a little bit
conflicted about this and and I can
understand why I think which is that
when when you wrote the book it was it
was talking about the the dangers of
consensus mechanisms because in fact I
think you were worried about the erosion
of human creativity and by extension
autonomy so you you so you're clearly
very concerned about paternalism but
then then we're in this situation now
with social media and and we can see how
easily humans are deranged by
um kind of like submitting to their you
know animal
um immediate instincts so so it's almost
like we need some paternalism but it
goes against your previous philosophy
yeah it's confusing I think
one way it's confusing is that at the
basis of a lot of our intuitions about
how Society institutions should work is
this idea of human autonomy
and
as we get better at optimizing our
environment as we learn more about human
psychology as we get better machine
learning systems
as we have faster iteration Loops doing
a b testing and things like that
the idea the idea of autonomy kind of
becomes under attack a little bit you
know like that we are a subject like the
optimization optimization does work I am
able to get addicted to things like
Facebook or Tick Tock or whatever
and
and so whether the antidote is some form
of paternalism
like like journalism in the strict sense
or whether it's
just something
that is helping you to to fend away this
optimization like another way of saying
it maybe machine love wouldn't at all be
necessary if we lived in an environment
where there's more alignment between
just our our instincts our evolved
instincts and the kind of affordances
and things coming at us and it seems
like that fit you know over time is just
kind of degrading as we change our
environment really quickly and there's a
lot of beautiful things that come from
that
um I don't want to go back to the cave
person days
um but the the sad or confusing thing is
that it's seemingly harder and harder
for us to figure out how to just live
happy fulfilled lives even as we have a
physical material abundance and it's
just there's something in that Paradox
or contradiction it's like if you feel
into it's like really sad like we have
all this abundance like we live better
than Kings did in uh in lots of ways we
have so much affordances that technology
affords us and and yet still like so
many are like lonely depressed sad
um it's it's kind of bizarre if you
think about it
so um a little bit of a quick fire
question now I kind of read one of one
of the core ideas in in the book is that
there's a challenge representing
subjectivity in machine learning models
therefore we we kind of almost look at
what's outside rather than what's inside
so quick fire question do you think
subjective states are representable
yes so I think so I mean I guess I am
more kind of a materialist
I could be you know it might be changed
on that but
in my mind there's nothing necessarily
magical about us for the products of
evolution as far as I know and that
there is some representation of
subjective things that is happening
somewhere in our brains as far as I
understand and so I don't think there's
a you know like a firewall between
um yeah The Human Experience or like
representing representing subjectivity
at least and machine learning but um I
guess I don't feel like super super
confident about that
yeah I mean because we'll get into
computationalism and and there's you
know sales argument as well and and you
could argue that yeah it is perfectly
representable in in silico but it's
vegan and complex so there might be
computational challenges or certainly
statistical challenges but but then then
you can move into the whole empiricism
thing as well so do you think subjective
states are deducible from observable
information so in in your framework that
would be actions is it possible to go
from actions to subjective experience
I'm less sure about that
I would still lean towards yes and that
observing actions can be quite broad or
observing something in the world you
know because conversation is a form of
kind of interaction between us and
it seems at least for humans who are
kind of calibrated because we have come
from the same you know genetic
origin
um you know we can talk about subjective
experience we can still miss each other
it's not even
sometimes in conversations it's hard to
get a feel for where someone's coming
from
but I think
I'd be optimistic that through
through conversational interaction
potentially the observations of what's
going on in our heads if we had better
brain scanners or something
that you
you could do it yeah
so um I'm sure I'm sure you're familiar
with Thomas Nagel's famous thought
experiment what is it like to be a bat
um you know he questioned the limits of
our understanding of subjective
experience uh specifically arguing that
they can't you know we can't truly
comprehend the experience of being a bat
due to the fundamentally different
nature of their sensory experience and
in the context of machine love where AI
is being you know designed to support
human flourishing without replicating
human emotions or subjective experience
I just wondered how you would address
the challenge posed by Nagel's argument
I mean is is there a way for AI to
sufficiently understand human
experiences and needs without truly
experiencing them or is there a kind of
inherent limit to ai's ability to you
know empathize and effectively support
human flourishing
yeah it's a very deep and good question
and I have some uncertainty about it I
would be optimistic
and one reason I would be optimistic is
that so much of human experience has
been written about
um and just
we were discovering that
simply
training models to predict the next word
and then going beyond that with our late
shaft and other things really does just
empirically seem to Grant
a Model A significant amount of
if not understanding I know it's a kind
of a complicated word and we might mean
different things by it but practical
workability with
Concepts that are familiar to us that
are relative you know relevant in
Psychology
um so like one of the things in the
paper was just a kind of a quick side
experiment almost was showing that the
models seem to be able to predict how
people would behave according to
different
um attachment Styles that's just a kind
of one one psychological facet of a
person is um you know what kind of
attachment style you have and that might
influence how you relate to romantic
partner partners and other important
people in your life
I guess I just in playing with language
models
just empirically I'm surprised by how
how much information is in just the
written the written
um
exhaust of humans um it just it does
seem like there's something there so
like practically speaking then on the
philosophical level
could a machine ever truly understand us
um as well as we understand uh each
other
I think there I'm also still optimistic
or while I'm just not sure if optimistic
is the right word
um but because I worry about it as well
is that I think that it's possible
but
I think in a practical level yes like
enough
to potentially understand it's more more
people than than ourselves and that's
kind of worrisome as much as it is
exciting
but like then truly like I can't
remember the some philosophical thought
experiment where you know you know all
the atoms of a person's head or
something but then uh you know they
experience color for the first time and
still it seems like there's something
you truly learn that's different there
and oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and so like I
don't think that I think that still
machines wouldn't have that level of
currently they don't have
phenomenological experience and
potentially maybe will never I don't
know you know I think that's an open
question but I I don't think that they
would understand on the same level
because they haven't experienced things
at all
um yeah I mean so we can we can agree
that there is a spectrum of
understanding right because if it's
binary if you either understood it or
you didn't then that that's quite an
extreme position and and that's
basically what cells says so it it's
exactly what you just said understanding
is about Fidelity right it's about
sufficiently representing a mental state
and some mental states are so complex
and observer relative that it becomes as
Nagel said it becomes increasingly
difficult to represent them and that's
why I mean they go at the end of his um
what it's like to be a bad article we
introduce this concept of an objective
phenomenology which is like a
theoretical framework that might allow
us to understand the subjective
experience of others and I was using
gpt4 last night and I'm constantly
amazed I just can't get I can't get my
head around it it's insane and you know
it's so so there are there's a spectrum
there's modes of understanding it's a
receding Horizon so we don't we don't
necessarily have to have this black and
white notion of an understanding but
what's so surprising to me is you know
sir always thought that all of this
subjective
um ontologically subjective as he would
call it that domain of understanding the
the the Horizon of the models are
actually sweeping much further into that
domain than I ever thought they would do
yeah it's I find myself surprised as
well
I didn't see the you know the leap from
gpt2 to gpd3 and
it's been
strange to
see just how far this Paradigm of
more parameters more data really goes
and it is surprising
um I don't think you know if you told me
20 years ago since I was going to go I
would have been skeptical for sure
um it is really
surprising
but you're you're an alignment man and I
think this might have implications for
alignment because if if the
um if the state of of a mind an
artificial mind is so infinitely
fractionated and complicated that would
presumably pose a problem for alignment
but if there is I mean gpt4 is still
extremely complicated it's a very big
model but you know but if if there is a
kind of objective phenomenology doesn't
that give you hope for alignment
that's interesting I haven't considered
a lineman from a phenomenological point
of view
for whatever reason I think it doesn't
give me much
relief
um but I haven't thought about it deeply
and it's simply that I think we don't
have
alignment techniques that in the limit
don't break
um so like that the reinforcement
learning through human feedback is kind
of like
from like a psychological point of view
at least it's a like a training where
you're saying meet my approval as a
human like just you're you're seeking my
approval and that's your only goal and
there's lots of ways to seek approval
that aren't going to be aligned with my
goals and I mean it's a longer
conversation there about why we might
need
better alignment methods I mean I'm
really I think rhf is like incredible I
think it's a great technique and it's
better than anything else we've had
um but I guess just the incentives just
don't seem to align I think in the
bottom line just figuring out how to how
to make those things align better
um is still an unsolved problem but
potentially something in phenomenology
you know could help I think we need to
think really broadly when it comes to
alignment and I think it's really easy
to get stuck in particular paradigms of
thought
um
yeah yeah it's interesting it's almost
like where I was going with that is some
mental states are phenomenal and and
some some are you know more objective
but um this this all points to the cons
the con sorry one second
my God this all points to the concept of
um abstraction or because I like to
think of abstraction and generalization
as being similar Concepts I mean chole
Francois Chalet talks about type 1 and
type 2 generalization and the type 2
generalization is what most people call
abstraction but let's just call it all
abstraction so you know when when you
abstract something you create an
interface you know to something
underneath which is more complicated and
abstraction doesn't work very well
um in in large language models and ml
systems but but in a sense you're
talking about abstraction with love so
you you said the paper argues that
progress and machine learning has
arrived at the precipice of enabling
fruitful Research into machine love
abstracting principles of love and
implementing them in machines to support
human flourishing and you said no
irreducible obstacles prevent its
meaningful synthesis with machine
learning so we're talking about
abstracting love so creating an
interface to overcome the brittleness of
of a complex phenomenon but wouldn't the
abstraction be lossy you know what would
it mean to abstract love in your opinion
yeah so I think
One Challenge in abstracting love is
deciding even among the all the
different facets of what we associate
with love what we want to focus on
and different people would have
different ideas there
um and someone's just like narrowing in
on just you know particular definition
um and so like you know from my point of
view was thinking that
um
loving action so just an action-based
kind of framework might be more fitting
for machines to get to sidestep the need
for them to have or simulate on that
factor relationships
and certainly that abstraction will
still be bossy with current models
and loss in the sense that
their understanding of what is meant by
in like in the froms kind of you know
um system things like respect or
um knowledge and he means kind of very
specific kind of qualitative things by
those things and those words themselves
are used in kind of atypical ways
and to actually create a system that's
going to like reliably Act
within those the confines of those those
rules is difficult and so it's true like
it's not going to be perfect and why I
think we're at the precipice of where
this kind of research could be useful is
that at least we have working
working models
that
that there's something there at least
that hasn't like it doesn't it's not
crazy to think about this it's true it's
not perfect and we know that there do
exist ways to kind of robustify the
capabilities of
of models like with fine-tuning with
more data using using you know experts
to
um to give feedback to drive an RL HF
process
uh and so I think there's there's
promise to to kind of get things going
in the right direction
and I think in some sense it's almost
like orthogonal to the alignment problem
and that progress on that would be of
help here or any kind of progress that
would make machine learning models more
robust could also help
um and one of the hopes for starting
this now is I guess I'm worried about
the impact that machine learning is
going to continue to have on us and and
even though it's not perfect right now
and it is lossy as you say
um I just have this kind of feeling we
need to get started soon
um to have tools to help us to deal with
just the
um
to have machine learning on our side as
well as kind of
a little bit of pose to us
indeed but because you said in your
paper that love is a suitcase word so it
is it's an innately complex phenomenon
and the Greeks had six words for Love
Actually uh Eros or sexual passion uh
failure or deep friendship ludus or
playful love uh agapa a love for
everyone pragma long-standing love and
um uh fill out here the love for oneself
so you know in in your paper you spoke
about love as a skill and that was what
you were just kind of speaking to and um
it brings to my mind the inactivist
project
um which is basically
um thinking through affordances and and
using the world as its own
representation but but but also you
could argue it's a Revival of pure
behaviorism
um as it often rejects the notion of
mental States so um you know one you
said in your paper by the way uh one
possible guiding principle is the idea
of love as a practical skill that is one
view um found within both psycho therapy
and philosophy is that it's a critical
facet of love that goes beyond its
emotional experience it's concerned with
the learnable art of supporting others
in their growth and development so we're
thinking of kind of trajectories rather
than the here and now so um this
distinction is is evident When comparing
the transient teenage concept of love as
a feeling versus the more mature
long-term understanding of love as a
series of Acts and habits and committed
willpower and so on so with that in mind
do you foresee the need to curate the
information that language models are fed
to ensure that they focus on this more
mature concept of love and avoid being
influenced by the teenage feelings angst
you know often found on the internet and
and how can we strike the balance
between these two competing perspectives
of love when training AI systems and you
might want to comment on by the way
whether it's morally right to ignore the
machinations of of feeling entirely
yeah maybe I'd start with saying that
while I take a behaviorist lens towards
the language models I don't want to take
a behaviorist lens towards the people
interacting with them and so while the
machine is focused on loving actions
like these skills
it could be in support of the you know
the vast subjective experience of
individuals social make that distinction
that I don't yeah I want to worry or
about the subjective experience of the
machine
um I'm just assuming that that doesn't
exist and that could be wrong
um
and then
could you remind me the second part of
the question
oh yeah sure sorry yeah
yeah so so um we were talking about the
the dichotomy between
um modeling subjective state in the here
and now so you were talking about
Facebook before so people get locked
into this kind of a cycle of addiction
and and uh you know kind of pathological
Behavior versus this long-term planning
approach through trajectories of actions
and and modeling uh love in that way as
as a long-term thing
yeah it does seem like a lot of the
objectives that we use now
for machine Learning Systems make
assumptions about us almost as that we
are behavioral agents that we choose our
next action it's always optimal and so
on it doesn't depend on context which is
anathema I think to just how we
scientifically understand human minds
and behavior
I think you also asked about kind of
like the training data of like whether
we would want to steer the model away
from more infantile or I guess he's a
teenage versions of of love I kind of
like that are more you know driven by
the the passions which which are
beautiful experiences and I don't have
any judgment towards that
I think that yeah when it comes to like
how we steer the model towards its
understanding of I guess these in if we
want to take problems framework these
four principles of love then
I think the way to sidestep it is to
focus on those those kind of core
principles and it may not even invoke
the word love necessarily when
interacting with the model as much as
saying um you know here is this kind of
principle of respect that we really want
to care about the user for their own
ends like the user is an end in itself
want to support them growing and
flourishing you know in their own lights
and you don't actually have to invoke
the word love there necessarily it's
more kind of like the love is kind of um
how from thinks about decomposing into
these four components and there's like
different ways you could decompose it
different ways you can think about love
and loving action
um and so I guess that's kind of maybe
how I would start to think about it
I mean one interesting thing to bring in
here and and kind of where I was going
with this is um later on we will talk I
mean like effective altruists and the
rationalist community and long-termism
and so on then and there's a really
interesting dichotomy because they say
that what they are advocating for is
technical empathy as opposed to real
empathy so empathy is what you feel and
Technical empathy is maximizing utility
function so it's almost like they're
being somewhat autistic about it because
they don't fit you know they're being
very rigorous and mathematical and
they're saying let's let's plan to
maximize utility in the future and in a
way that that's that it feels like
that's what you're saying so you're
saying rather than the the the the rural
emotion of love now let's actually model
it as as a TR as an optim well maybe
optimal trajectory of of actions is is
that fair
from that perspective before
I I think I wouldn't
wholeheartedly agree with that
characterization
um because
the feelings of like the human feelings
of love that we have I would want an
ideal machine Learning System to
encourage human love like those feelings
the depth of those things like an
important part of our experience and not
that it's optimizing us towards just
beautiful experience
um because I think the principle of like
respect or autonomy would mean like it
would encourage us to make our own
mistakes
um I think like an ideal kind of one way
of thinking about like a mentor or
something or someone who's just
supporting you
um they're not gonna I think in my mind
at least an ideal Mentor wouldn't be so
paternalistic as say like you know we
have to optimize this out to you know
the next year or something but more that
it's going to maybe help you identify
patterns that are kind of like keeping
you from from flourishing
um and there is some tension here which
is interesting attention being
um and I think it's actually inherent in
kind of maybe our own ideas of love
ourselves and in France principles that
there is a care for the other and it
might hurt us it wouldn't hurt the
machine necessarily but if it hurt like
if you are
um you have a friend that you you love
that you're supporting and you see them
kind of replaying the same pattern over
and over again and you might wish that
they not do that
um for their own sake but as a friend
you aren't going to kind of technically
personally say maybe like you must do
this or something
or here is like the optimized you know
20-step plan
um first of all if you gave them the
online 20 set plan they probably
wouldn't do it but even if they did
now they're just depending on you and
now you're kind of like the guide for
them and there's something that doesn't
sit right at least in the way I think
about love
for that and I guess I so somehow just
yeah again I guess there's this tension
and maybe this paper was an attempt to
try to
even just get my own thoughts clear on
this and I'm still maybe not perfectly
clear because it's a really complex
thing but
yeah uh yeah I mean I mean that you're
so right there is there is a real
tension and it seems to run deep through
the spirit of of humanity and even if
you look in politics for example you
know some some people think individual
responsibility private Enterprise other
people think you know kind of central
planning and control and you were
speaking to this in in your book that
you know just like can't said we choose
our own actions we have autonomy we have
creativity these are the things that you
that you're advocating for and then you
just spoke to well sometimes um humans
become pathological like you know they
um remember those Tamagotchis in the
1990s those little key rings and people
would fall in love with that and and
some people
um develop weird obsessions with theme
park rides or something like that and
this is wire heading this is where the
brain you can't trust the brains I mean
that's an extreme example but but but
you know everyone has this kind of wire
heading
um kind of potential where their
experience and flourishing will be
truncated so that's why we can't have a
pure appeal to autonomy and creativity
we need to have a balance of this ying
and the Yang you know the the autonomy
but but also the the planning
yeah I think one thing that
is maybe not as well appreciated as as
maybe would be useful is that when we
talk about
alignment sometimes we talk about the
alignment between like the AI and our
interests but we create institutions
ourselves to align ourselves like that's
so it's it's like we we kind of in some
sense understand some of this problem
um and I think in some ways there is
attention fundamentally in some ways
maybe taking a zoomed out view the
attention at least disappears a little
bit which is that you know on you know
some there's there's a tension between
the the progressives and the
conservatives
um I think there's intelligence in that
tension
um
and if conservatives kind of assume that
humans have this
um almost like a Libertarian kind of
notion of humans that we are autonomous
and that letting humans do what they
want is kind of the best way forward
I think that's true given you have a
context that supports that that like
like education for example and ideally
kind of prepares us
for what it really means to be
autonomous like it's not something that
just comes to us
um because critical thought is required
for us to truly be autonomous I think
um to understand ourselves in some level
and how things will and won't influence
us
and we design our institutions in theory
to kind of give us this coherence you
know that education prepares us to
participate in democracy which will help
us to keep the power structures that
that influence us
um you know ideally aligned with us in
some way and similar to you know the
market has its pros and cons
and
the the pros that it you know gives us
what we want and the cons are that it
sometimes the tail can Wag the Dog a
little bit and it you know there's like
image based advertising which isn't
about the product but kind of gets us to
buy things and it gets kind of messy and
complicated but
maybe what we need is
there's truth and we want to be
autonomous and we might need to rethink
some of our institutions just to help
support us in this new age of of where
autonomy might mean something different
because we're starting to you know play
at the edges of how much a machine can
kind of influence us in very subtle ways
and so when we think about you know
um
how much like with the rise of chat CPT
for example like just how many people
are interacting with these technological
systems at scale and how they could be
used to influence in very subtle ways
and how
um social media was a simpler technology
that it's kind of effects Upon Us
weren't well appreciated to later and
similar similar things could be true
with with this way as a wave of
technology and this is something I think
that the the center for Humane
technology talks about a lot and they're
they're good thinking on this and other
institutions are trying to think about
this as well just to prepare for how can
we rethink things a little bit how can
we prepare for this future where machine
learning is just I think uh Yeovil
Harari talks about it as well as well
just
in we're not exactly sure we're going
and machine learning could get a lot
better than it already is and we want to
be prepared for what that might mean
societally which could be very upsetting
or at least turbulent if we're not
careful
yeah I mean you said something so
interesting there which is um you know
we all agree the human individual humans
are irrational in fact that that's the
underpinning of basically every moral
framework in the world from religion to
effective altruism if you like but um
but but then but then you just said oh
well we create institutions so we've
actually got this um didactic kind of
circular causation between individual
humans and then and then if you look at
the macroscopic scale we've got
um emergence like let's say society and
as a society we are much more rational
and and we and we create these kind of
causal pressures yeah so there's like a
top-down causation to make us more
rational at the bottom and that that's
um that's actually a remarkable
phenomenon I hadn't really thought about
that
yeah it is a remarkable phenomenon and
it's confusing to think about
what we want that to do and where it's
going and what it means for that to be
better or worse functioning
and one way I sometimes think about that
is
is kind of the fit between
our
behavior and our environment
and
ideally we want our institutions to kind
of like adapt at the same rate that
we're kind of changing the environment
potentially
and when the environment changes much
more quickly than our institutions then
maybe that's when we start to get into
some trouble and it does seem like
technological progress has really
changed the landscape of our
institutions
relatively quickly like definitely
quickly relative to our genes which
change very slowly but also it seems
like our institutions are are kind of
were created a lot of them were created
um
in a time where technology moved much
more slowly and
they have an inertia of their own it's
hard to change like the voting system of
the us but we know that the first pass
the post and Electoral College stuff is
a little bit crazy but we just don't we
don't fix that for whatever reason and
it's
and the similar kind of other just
loopholes that exist in our systems our
institutions and we have trouble keeping
up with them and
it seems like that that is one sign
maybe that things are starting to go a
little bit Haywire is when
there's no coherence between our
institutions where like ideally they're
kind of
fitting us in a way with our environment
so that you know it's relatively easy
for us to to you know to flourish and to
live a good life and be happy to be
socially connected and all those things
we want
and yeah it just seems like right now
there's there's just not as much of that
coherence
I completely agree I mean when we spoke
to Luciano floridi um at Oxford he was
talking exactly you know he said exactly
the same thing so um the pace of change
in society is accelerating the info
sphere is is I mean there's always been
information but the the scale and the
magnitude has increased dramatically and
um he said that there's basically no
friction whatsoever between the legal
landscape and and Technology anymore and
you know by extension between
um institutions and and Society so um
yeah it it's it's really weird because
there is this fundamental yin and yang
as you were saying in your greatness
can't be planned book all of these
consensus mechanisms they're almost
designed as a regularizing force because
we are so chaotic if left to our own you
know it's very creative and open-ended
as you would say but but it it's almost
like we created these institutions for a
reason but so so the institutions
weren't designed to make Society
sclerotic but they were designed to
regularize so you have this kind of like
you know chaos and and order at the same
time and there's a live boundary of the
chaos but but now it feels like we're in
a regime where where the ying and the
Yang doesn't work anymore
yeah I think that's right it's
and it's hard to
I think it's something I'm so graphical
it's hard sometimes to find a language
to describe this
yeah it does seem like the the the
I think like ideally there's this kind
of tension between
uh you know maybe some good parts of
conservativism are like don't change
things that are really essential without
understanding them and in progressivism
which is like to move forward to make
changes to improve
and
you know there's something about those
two forces ideally that would keep us
relatively safe so like not changing
things too rapidly that things kind of
fall apart but also not getting stuck in
in kind of maladaptive
patterns
um
but
yeah there's something about just the
way that technology is kind of just
arcing forward
so fast
and
it's so hard to understand the
implications of what's happening or
what's coming like the second and Order
effects whatever from
deploying things and it and at least it
seems like the reigning philosophy kind
of in the market right now is just kind
of like just go full steam ahead
um because there's money to be made and
and I mean capitalism is a great thing
in many ways like I'm I don't know that
there's a better system and yet it seems
like yeah we need different kinds of
regular Rising pressure like
maybe we need to rethink how we
can
regulate some of these Technologies in a
way that's like they can keep up with it
I'm not sure what that looks like
um so it's definitely kind of you know
getting outside the sphere of what I
really understand but it does seem like
we need to rethink things and something
needs to change and attention there
again is like you don't want to change
things willy-nilly too quickly and just
create something worse
um and yet it does feel like we're
there's like a certain urgency I'm
feeling as machine learning in
particular just kind of rockets ahead
that I don't know that we know how this
is going to change society and you know
some of those changes can be really
great
um so I'm not like a like a necessarily
A Doomer but it does seem like there's a
lot more ways to break the coherence of
things than there is to keep it together
yeah and and nobody knows I mean it's
like social media I mean let's not let's
not be a Doomer about it it's it's in
some ways been um a huge positive force
for society many many bad things about
it and it might even be part of the
solution as well but um it's the same
thing with with these large language
models it's happened so quickly because
now when when you think about it bing is
is basically ripping off the information
from stack Overflow and people don't
even need to visit stack Overflow
anymore they just go to Bing Bing tells
them the answer and now stack Overflow
if they made money out of advertising
presumably they went for much longer so
so this this is a new type of technology
which has no friction with the legal
landscape whatsoever and um it's been
done so quickly that they they just
hovered up all of this data nobody said
anything about it and and it's but these
models are out in the open now so you
can't really draw up the the bridge and
say oh no stop using those language
models guys you know we don't want you
to use it but I mean just just bringing
it back to machine learning for a second
I mean we can give a concrete example
um so you know like ensuring AI system
understand and account for the
complexities of human needs and emotions
as is important because we're talking
about living in a pluralistic society
here we don't want to have like a
monolithic approach and and then I could
just I can think of an example so we
need to balance the need for
personalization and machine learning
systems with the risk of reinforcing
existing patterns and hindering growth
so there seems like a fundamental
challenge that
yeah
and maybe there's a way to you know
navigate through without there being a
contradiction or a paradox
which is I think personalization is
really needed because we are each
different people with different values
and different things that we want to do
and become
and personalization could be into our
kind of immediate wants like I think
often happens right now like that's
probably what most things are optimizing
for or it could be personalization
to support you
towards what you really the directions
you really want to go and there's there
is some tension there I think because
um
you know as much as I say that I want to
you know learn new things about
philosophy in particular I think
philosophy is really interesting and I
would love to dive more into it
um sometimes I go to Netflix and I you
know I'm not watching a documentary
about philosophy I'm just kind of you
know zoning out watching something that
I might regret afterwards but like I
don't know that I want a machine
Learning System to kind of be like like
no you can't do that
um and so maybe it's just like attention
within ourselves too like just when are
we you know sometimes you just want to
relax and and not have to like always be
growing and developing and challenging
ourselves
um it's like a balance there
um
and maybe there's like a soft touch
um I don't know like for me sometimes
I'm watching
YouTube clips of Saturday Night Live for
whatever reason that's one of my little
minor addictions and maybe if you know
there's something like the first two I
watch are kind of like mildly funny and
then I just kind of like just there and
so if I could check in or something
maybe I could tell it like hey would you
check in after a couple times and and
you know potentially redirect me to or
something like if not exactly
educational but like a little more
um in the landscape of all the wonderful
beautiful artistic content that Humanity
has created that's not in this narrow
niche
yeah and you you reminded me of a bit in
your greatness plan book where you're
talking about the Scandinavian schools
that don't really have like a rigorous
um curriculum they just have this
creative exploration and and yeah I mean
in many ways this is the philosophy of
my life as well now after reading your
book but I I can sense that there's this
like
um real conflict deep inside you because
there is there is this sense that you
know like we are told like self-help and
be the best version of yourself and like
have goals and be driven and all the
stuff you spoke about in in your book
and that that is that is the prevailing
meme in society and there's so much more
to human flourishing than than that you
know
but yeah I don't know if you want to
comment on that and I'll move on to the
next yeah yeah
um yeah living right now live in San
Francisco and there's yeah all this
self-helpy kind of pressure to grow and
develop it feels like everyone's doing
that here or something
um
and it can get a little bit mechanical
it's
I mean yeah life is also involves play
and just connecting with people and you
know these are these are kind of needs
that we have like from like the
masolovian kind of sense need for
belonging need for
um
it's that fun
but isn't isn't there like a weird thing
here that even if you did what I mean
even if even if you did want to maximize
your own utility
um this goal seeking self-help stuff
because you're an expert in in
open-ended search it's naive because as
as you said in the book you know the the
greatest stepping stones in our life
tend to be pretty strange and you find
them serendipitously so it's uh it would
be a stupid thing to do anyway like from
a from a search optimization uh problem
even if you did want to be successful
I think that's true and there's
something that confuses me about it
um because it could be that as we come
to understand human psychology more and
more
you know maybe there is
um some intervention that would apply to
nearly all of us and kind of
have a cell kind of self-help you feel
and it would really really you know help
our flourishing or something like
um one of them kind of like you know
esoteric kind of example is that
um you know a lot of people enjoy
meditation and it's like this kind of
activity we're just like sitting there
for a while and
um
one way to think about meditation is
this kind of this practice that
developed over thousands of years of
people kind of like maybe trying to
jailbreak their mind or they probably
didn't think of it at that time and in
the same way that like speedrunners
playing video games
um find weird exploits in the system by
doing strange things that kind of view
meditation the same way like you're you
know drawing your mind out of
distribution really far and you find
some kind of exploit and in theory you
find your way out of suffering
um and none of us really want to suffer
um and so if there was a way you know
that that technology could be developed
further or something where it was didn't
require years of sitting in a cave or
something to to really become
enlightened and a lot of people wanted
to become enlightened
um then maybe there would be almost like
a universal prescription or something
but maybe not I'm not sure
um
but it is like a bit I found my mind
muddled about it because it's true like
I think each of us do face currently in
particular I think we do I think it's
true that we each face our own hard
exploration problem and maybe that is
just intrinsic to human The Human
Condition maybe there's no way for there
to be Universal prescriptions of things
that kind of really help us to
find our way
um that's not you know just deeply
individual deeply you there is some solo
aspect of it like you have to struggle
you have to kind of look around
but also I'm not really completely sure
about that I wouldn't be surprised if
with a deeper understanding of the human
mind that we we could change the Human
Condition in a way that's just much more
Humane
um
and so it might like lean sort of like
into transhumanish kind of dimensions
and I'm like a little bit you know
ambivalent about that kind of stuff but
I think
I would imagine that there could be
something there where we make life just
easier for all of us in some ways
yeah I completely agree I'm a bit
careful about mentioning transhumanism
because um we we spoke about it with
Mike Levin recently and the load of
people in our Discord Community said
that apparently it's got connotations
attached to it I'm not sure if you're
aware about that but yeah yeah that'd
definitely be the case yeah I think like
there could be um
yeah problematic associations with it
and I
um
enough about it yeah
I I was completely naive to it as well
but apparently then there are there are
negative connotations attached to it but
um I'm sure people disagree strongly
about that but but no I I loved your um
invoking meditation because that is a
that is actually a beautiful example of
what we're speaking about here it's
almost like the first example of this
um open-endedness and and it's by
definition the ontological subjective
right so it's it's my sense of being or
existing and it's subjective in the
sense that it's ineffable and it's
fascinating you listen to Sam Harris's
waking up happen it's it's hilarious
listening to him try and come up with
ways to verbalize and explain what you
should do I mean the first thing
everyone says during meditation is
um it's not an end in itself just like
you say there's there's no end there's
no end state in fact it's a cul-de-sac
to think of it as an end in itself it
has to be an intrinsically open-ended
um process and if if anything it's about
developing a form of of meta awareness
but um yeah so so Sam Harris would say
just just imagine that you've got no
face and and just and just place place
your head behind the man with the nofa
and it it is I I admire him for trying
it's brilliant yeah meditation is like
just mind-bending in lots of different
ways and I agree there is this kind of
paradoxical nature to it where it's
almost you have to let go of trying to
get to where you're going in order to
get there and I guess that's why
sometimes when talking about greatness
cannot be planned we kind of know notice
like the zen-like kind of
Paradox of like to reach your greatest
objectives you might be willing to to
abandon them
um and it is fascinating these different
kinds of like pointing out instructions
um where in some some verbal language
can sometimes trigger within you is some
kind of uh spiritual recognition which
is like interesting like I think for
some people that thing about like
imagining you have no face when you
first hear it
um there's also this thing called like
the Headless way which is developing
that more um
yeah it's like we're trying again find
like maybe ways to you know Point
towards the moon where the Moon is
something weird and strange that is
at least it's like um
I guess maybe what I would say is like
we're evolved so that
there's some defense to like this
jailbreaking because if everyone was
able like like basically maybe suffering
is one engine that
um Evolution uses that you know to push
us to replicate to be successful in the
world you know towards its its aims and
you know we being reasoning creatures
can realize like hey like maybe I don't
want exactly what evolution wants if I
could escape from suffering that'd be
great
um and it's trying to find these kind of
like edge cases to kind of like pop
yourself out of
um the simulator that Evolution has kind
of created for us so it's it's
interesting the way I really enjoy how a
lot of the concepts in machine learning
and openness can be you know applied as
like a lens into trying to understand
other you know phenomenon uh like I
think open-endness has been like a
really
powerful
um just
world view for I'm trying to understand
like myself and where I get stuck I was
a very objective driven person in some
ways to lamb
um but just doing the research myself
like you know it's not really search
like you can't help but have that impact
you
um
but still it's uh it's confusing
sometimes
and and I think I'm conflicted because
as I said it moved me but I mean anyone
looking at me would still say Tim you're
a very objective driven person and I
guess I kind of compartmentalized too
simultaneously but a bit like the
jungian idea that you know good and evil
runs through the middle of everyone and
and I feel that you know I've got these
two states coexisting at the same time
but um yeah the meditation thing's
really interesting uh I mean I I had a
yoga teacher and we would often meditate
and part of me didn't like it because it
was almost like he was instructing me to
lobotomize myself because many people
that come to his classes they they have
many sources of suffering and most
sources of suffering come from the
social program so um you know he would
basically say that um all of the rules
that you've inherited from the social
program like social status and the need
to do this and like these expectations
you know he was um he used the thought
experiment of a sadhu which is a type of
person who basically doesn't participate
in society at all and it's almost like
this Zen
um kind of objective if like maybe you
could call it objective what was was to
only have sensory
um experience and and not really
participate in in anything whatsoever
and that feels like a kind of form of
escapism to me which which didn't
actually feel like something I wanted to
participate in
yeah I think it's really hard to be a
human in general
um because there's some Instinct in us
that's kind of like totalizing where
we're looking on some level for the one
principle that will save us and
um you know this kind of relationship
between a student and like um like a
meditation teacher yeah it could be like
the meditation teacher has all the
answers for like how to live a good life
um that oddly has this kind of like
seemingly cul-de-sac way that you you
end up living in a cave and doing
nothing and
it just doesn't seem like that's not the
life I want for myself maybe for some
people that's kind of Life they want but
it's almost like
meditation seems like an interesting
tool in many ways and it's like you it's
hard to resist the totalization and you
want to like make it your own and help
it support you living the life you want
and it seems like you know spiritual
teachers often have like strictly a
spiritual perspective and maybe not like
a scientific perspective maybe some you
know teachers have both
um but it feels like there's like this
integration of you know the all these
different parts of life and it's hard to
to balance it all and I wish there was
like a maybe that someone has like a you
know a book on how to how to balance uh
all these different kinds of impulses
within us but I think at some point I
was I think I remember when I was
younger I was really worried that I
would end up in a mental cul-de-sac
um I was kind of um more religious when
I was younger and you know more power
people that are religious um and it was
really difficult coming out of that
because I I didn't recognize just that
my own assumptions because they were so
deep-seated were limiting the way that I
could think and then kind of after I got
after I kind of left that world view
um
I said the sensitivity like okay maybe
science is gonna be this way for me now
like I'm just gonna kind of going down
this drought and you know I was kind of
went into that actually I was like in uh
really drawn to effective altruism in
some ways because it you know gave me
the one true way to live
um
and
and just kind of trying to find like a
balance between
um
how to live a good life and how to stay
true to yourself I mean it sounds kind
of weird to say it out loud
um but it just
again just maybe going back to what he
said like it's hard to be a person in
this world and know how to what you're
trying to do and what you want to become
yeah it's so interesting because um how
we think how we feel
um and what we pay attention to
determine so much about our mental state
and you you know you invoked effective
altruism religion and so on
um people like Jordan Peterson that I
think he's a narrativist which means he
he thinks that the way you construct
meaning is is through stories and and
narratives um you know may be told in
the Bible for example so there's this
huge kind of psychological framing in
terms of what the what the trajectory
space is you know we can we can Traverse
all of these paths but they're
determined by my mental state and
they're determined by what I know and
and what I've experienced previously and
um as you say it's almost like maybe you
did a form of jailbreaking by
recognizing you're in that situation and
managing to jump out of that Basin of
attraction
yeah
um one of my interests Beyond Machine
Love Is
is trying to
understand this is probably the wrong
framing like the human reward function
like what is it we're trying to do
um and so like one thing I got to do
when when writing the paper was to kind
of dive into the literature and like
human flourishing and
and from different lenses like from
Psychotherapy or from philosophy and I'm
still a dilettante in many ways like I'm
you know my core competency is machine
learning
um but there's no if you look across the
literature there's like no holistic
understanding it seems like like there's
no agreement about what we're here to do
as people necessarily or what the best
way to live your life
um you know there's like signposts you
know and there's like Maslow's hierarchy
and there's other models in Psychology
and
um yeah it all gets a bit confusing and
you know it seems like um yeah maybe
there never will be a definitive answer
to this
um and we just get to choose
what
what framework works for us the best
um or maybe there is a definitive answer
it's just fine I find it like
legitimately confusing which is
interesting
yeah and it comes back to our dichotomy
between subjective experience and
something which is objective and also
the the immediate and the the long term
I mean it's a little bit like if a lot
of folks that go to that meditation
class that I went to and I could sense
that they needed it they they had many
sources of suffering and
even then you could argue it both ways
so the meditation approaches to
basically not pay attention to your
suffering you could go to a CBT
um a trainer and their approach would be
exposure therapy you know which is
basically deliberately exposing yourself
to your suffering and then in terms of
utility You could argue that well maybe
the utility is just that we feel
overwhelming Joy all the time or you
could just take cocaine all day so that
doesn't sound very good uh or maybe
there could be some objective framework
you know traversing over the long term
and some societal benefit and so on but
as you say that even if you look at
effective altruism the way that they
measure utility is is extremely
subjective and arbitrary so how do you
do it
yeah I really wish I had an answer to
that and then maybe we all wish there
was a good answer to that and I think
they probably are better and worse
answers at least
um in that
um
when you
walk down like the Stanford encyclopedia
philosophy on like well-being or
something you know it's like you know
some positions and counter examples and
thought experiments that kind of like
highlight how
seemingly implausible of you actually is
um
but yeah it's profoundly confusing to me
yeah and there's so many ways of looking
at it I mean um because you have more
moral realists and and moral relativists
and the the religions tend to be
deontological so they tend to come up
with moral principles and and they think
you're a good person if you act in a
certain way and then we know we were
speaking about effective altruism which
is a form of extreme consequentialism
and utility so there's so many different
Frameworks about how to be a good person
yeah and
um
so so like machine love isn't my first
kind of foray into trying to meld the
philosophical with um with machine
learning and so the previous paper I
wrote with Adrian McAfee and back when I
was at Uber AI was on
moral uncertainty in reinforcement
learning and so the idea there was
we don't really know what the correct
moral principle is
and certainly if it were a program
programmed into machine we wouldn't want
it to be an extreme utilitarian or
deontologist because we know of the
problems with each of those
um
philosophies taken individually but for
perhaps like a guiding principle would
be like well we don't know which one's
right and so we'll actually have this
probability distribution over what you
know some allocation what we think the
right theorems potentially could be and
that
in formalizing that you should not act
in ways that are really problematic by
any of those
um in the extreme
and at least as I live my own life I
think I do that kind of I mean I'm not
looking through a formal sense from
calculating the probabilities of of
whether I'm being a utilitarian or
deontologist or like living through
virtue ethics but I think each of those
frames
you know has something valuable
um and there may be a way to kind of
integrate that through saying like you
know I really don't know what the the
correct one is but
um and I think that's something that I I
think effect revolves a reason I think
is like a wonderful Endeavor in the
sense of wanting to bring you know the
head and heart together and to do good
with reason I think that's beautiful
and I think there's a way where like
many fields it's hard to take yourself
seriously enough
um what I mean is like that like the one
of the prominent people in that
Community this guy named William
mccaskill I think he's one of the
founders um a really great person
um the youngest
um philosopher to make it in in this
University I can't remember the exact
story but um he was a someone who really
did a lot of work in moral uncertainty
and it seems like that's not something
that was taken seriously enough within
the effect of altruism Community I mean
this is those would be my personal
opinion I mean maybe there's kind of
arguments to it but that utilitarianism
and then the kind of like long-termest
kind of view
um is is just one
one possible moral philosophical View
and even if you subscribe to that
having enough maybe you could say like
epistemic uncertainty about how the
world actually works
um that really near-term considerations
are linked profoundly to the long term
and I think there's many effective
altruism altruists might
um really acknowledge that and know that
but
it seems like in in some way by focusing
on the on the forest future it's almost
alienating to other people that aren't
effective altruists and so lots of
narratives kind of arise about these you
know
strange people that are
um focusing on really exotic problems
while the world's currently burning and
there's a lack of
people might criticize and say there's a
lack of real empathy for the present
and if you wanted to be successful from
like a steely-eyed kind of like focus on
the far future way it doesn't seem like
it actually
um
it seems to work yet um although I once
again I think like it's great that
people are thinking about the far future
I'm definitely concerned about things
like AI safety
um and I think it's great that people
are thinking about that but there's
something about the movement I guess
still doesn't feel quite it's like
integrated to me
yeah I mean there's a few things to pick
up on them first of all um we had on
Carla Zoe Crema from Oxford University
she she wrote a very famous opinion
piece about effective altruism just
after the FTX Scandal and um it was
actually picked up on philosophy two
which got millions of views so her
article was referenced on that a couple
of a couple of weeks ago but um yeah you
know some some people talk about whether
it's the um the focus on AI risk or some
people focus on is it the long-termism
and um is it the FTX Scandal and there's
lots of theories about why the
credibility of effective altruism has
been a little bit stained recently but
on on the consequentialism thing I mean
just quoting Sam Harris he often gives
the example of uh in our country if a
little girl fell down a well there would
be helicopters there'd be 24-hour news
coverage and so on and go go and go to
Sudan where people might be getting
massacred every single day and as soon
as it comes up on the news you switch to
the next Channel you just don't care you
know so our moral programming is clearly
broken clearly we we need to expand our
cone of moral responsibility and we need
to think more spatially and and more
temporally but unfortunately when you
start rolling out too far into the
future it becomes so academic and
unintelligible to the average person and
and also I think our moral intuitions
really flare up and you say well hold on
a minute there's there's real problems
on on Earth today now and you're talking
about the hypothetical of an AI super
intelligence or or whatever in the
future
yeah
and
is there a way that we can worry about
both
because I think both are I'm really glad
that people are thinking about these
kinds of you know far future things
because I don't know some maybe the math
does work out in some ways that we
should be really concerned about that
and yeah moral intuitions in that space
are a little bit unclear I think like
one thing I've always been confused
about is do we really have a moral
obligation to bring new flourishing
lives into existence like the so like
one of the
things you you might conclude is we need
to really maximize our um you know
potential to the universe and tile the
universe with more
um flourishing people and I know for me
that moral intuition doesn't necessarily
go through it so people can disagree
about these things
um
and I think it doesn't have to be a
contradiction between you know worrying
about the far future and the present and
again I think like a moral uncertainty
would give us a far away there and so
maybe part of the
issue or what people maybe take umbrage
with is that some people are
specializing to to concern themselves
only with the far future because that's
something that's like underappreciated
and in some ways that seems really great
that people would would if they're if no
one else is focused on that it's good to
focus on that
and based on the problems just the
Optics of it and that's a little bit
concerning as well like like you said
like our
moral intuition is about you know one
person in a while versus an entire
country that's suffering a horrendous
genocide like that it's very different
and you know maybe there's some work we
could do educationally to kind of help
us you know get a better felt sense for
the ways that our moral intuitions are
wrong like one thing that's just
interesting to me is
how sometimes we take science for
granted
um when you think about just you know
how many horrendous diseases don't exist
that that do exist and only from the
virtue of of us discovering things like
antibiotics and vaccines
I think it's really easy to understand
intellectually but like just imagine
like that you know if you have children
like one of them might have died by now
from some just horrendous disease and
like the suffering that you would have
experienced personally
um it's almost like there's some
sacredness in science not necessarily
it's like a religion but just like
sacredness and like how beautiful it is
that you know through our own reasoning
we're able to just drain this enormous
ocean of of suffering and we can live
longer more flourishing lives but just
our intuitions don't work that way it's
just easier again because of how we're
evolved too
pay attention to the concrete the nearby
the
the kind of the obvious kind of causal
links as opposed to more indirect stuff
and I don't know what the solution if
there is a solution to that but it is
just another example of how we're just
not really well fit right now to our
present environments and I don't know if
again it just feels like kind of like a
a challenging problem and I'm not sure
like how to
work at it
yeah and the other problem is even in
the western world there's never been I
mean I guess you could argue it both
ways I mean billions of people have been
taken out of poverty in the last two
decades but it feels like there's never
been more mental health and suffering
even in the western world and a lot of
that might be to do with relative
deprivation which is that it's not the
absolute level of of emancipation or
whatever it it's how you feel in in
relation to other people but I wanted to
move on to a little thought experiment
actually as we're talking about ethics
now so
um I wanted to explore you know in the
concept of machine love it it's it's
intriguing to consider the opposite
right which is what we might call
machine hate so both love and hate are
complex and nebulous Concepts but
thinking about their negation can
sometimes clarify our understanding so
if malicious actors were to work on
developing machine hate as a
Counterpoint to your proposal how do you
envision that that would kind of deviate
from our current AI landscape and the
concept of machine love that you've
presented and what insights could we
gain by examining this contrast and how
could it help us better understand the
ethical implications and potential
dangers with the development
that's a super creative question I
you know let me take a second to think
about that
so I guess if machine love as I
formulated in the paper is something
machines that support our growth and
development and machine hate would be
something yeah I should say um someone
on our Discord Community submitted to
that question I can't remember their
name but thank you very much
yeah that's a good a great question yeah
I mean this is kind of like a little too
convenient but like arguably
you know machine hate in that
formulation it's the opposite of keeping
us growing but it's more like keeping us
stagnant
like arguably that's sort of like
optimizing for engagement like if that's
keeping us in place and that's not
always the case because some things that
engage us are actually like enlivening
and are aligned with kind of our own
growth
um but
you know if a system is designed just to
keep us on it then there's like a level
of manipulation that in the incentives
that wouldn't be too far I think from
Machine Head but if there's actually
something that was maybe leaning into it
more directly like attempting to
move us from
our unique
desires of who we want to be towards
something else yeah it feels a lot like
manipulation it feels a lot like
um just drawing us into into you know
the stagnance uh like was it Brave New
World type kind of time thing where
we're just kind of
zoned out on on Soma
um
I guess in thinking about that I mean I
do even not from like a malicious actor
point of view but just from where like
the economic incentives lie
uh
I do worry about that and like not just
economic incentives but like the
incentives that politicians face for
like creating you know attack ads that
will convince us of
uh to vote for them
and it seems like sometimes attack ads
are kind of almost contentless like
they're just designed to kind of
uh ad hominem the other person and and
you can almost vote for anyone or
something
against them
so I I do think that like without we
should be worried about machine hate
arising naturally
and I guess that's one reason like like
some people worry about the you know the
Dual use considerations of of something
like machine love that's kind of diving
into psychological and I definitely
share those concerns
um so I think it's something to be
approached gingerly and not rushed or
not like scaled up immediately or
something which I don't think is you
know on the docket anyways
um yeah I do worry about just like the
where the status quo takes us
because I'm speaking with um Carl
friston about this last week because
he's got this vision for this next
Generation collective intelligence which
is we're in the info sphere now we have
third order technology but you know most
most of the the websites and the
technology are still dumb they're not
intelligent autonomous agents but
eventually they they might be and
already now we have hate speech and we
have all sorts I mean like we have um
like the Russian government for example
um trying to influence elections and
it's entirely conceivable especially
with modern day language model
technology that there could be actors
out there who could deliberately try to
you know either
um spread misinformation or
disinformation and try and change
society
and because we're not talking about one
centralized
monolithic AI that controls the world
are we I mean it will actually be this
kind of collective ecosystem of agents
and systems and people all kind of
coming together and then what emerges
out of that is interesting because
governments now they try and influence
your behavior through nudging you
but it's very arbitrary they they do
like leaflet campaigns media they go and
talk on the BBC News and so on whereas
now we're talking about this
industrialization of of kind of nudging
through social media through technology
through language models through how we
communicate and what's acceptable to be
spoken about that kind of thing so it
does feel like it could be a big problem
yeah it's something I worry about a lot
um
and having like work to machine learning
you know gives me misgiving sometimes or
second thoughts about
um
about like the legacy of what I've done
so far like just it's just worrisome
when you see kind of like the the
strange things that could happen to us
in the future and
yeah it seems like
I'm not sure exactly of what's best to
counteract
those kinds of influences just that
it does seem like as models get better
and better they will be more able to
subtly influence us
um
just kind of a continuation of what
advertising and propaganda and
um just other you know methods that
people use to try to influence us
and it's you know it seems like we need
some kind of Defense layer like you
could imagine something that's
identifying how much optimization
pressure has been
put into something so maybe it's kind of
maybe we could create systems that would
recognize man this seems super well
tailored to hit you where you're
insecure
um that's that kind of research I think
would be really really great
um to somewhat insulate us or you could
imagine like you know the most
um maybe silly version of this is is
like a noising filter for everything
that's coming at you
um in the sense that if something is
well optimized to influence you then
just adding some noise to it changing
the word subtly
um maybe that has some do some work and
making it less you know manipulable
and I think this is a an area that needs
you know a lot of study and there are I
think there are some people looking at
this there's um the the AI objectives
Institute is one kind of organization
I'm kind of affiliated with it's looking
at that there's the collective
intelligence project as well that kind
of is in this space and I think there's
other organizations are starting to look
at these kind of more
yeah collective intelligence
um
what is how can we help Society to steer
itself in this new age of Technology
yeah there are so many potential
problems that that could arise I mean
the the obvious one that I'm sure you
would speak to because of your book is
is the erosion of human autonomy and um
and you know and and our dignity and so
on and this is what Luciano fluidi spoke
about so he said that the infosphere is
causing a re-ontologization of human
society so what that basically means is
that it's compressing our existence
because we basically increasingly exist
through technology you know so with you
can't live off the grid anymore and he
talks about there being a third order
technology now so your humanity is three
steps removed from technology and you
know our digital identity is becoming
abstracted and fractionated and so on
um so so yeah I think that the autonomy
is is a big risk but I also wanted to
talk about the the future of um kind of
human and machine relationships so as as
AI continues to evolve and become more
sophisticated the line between machines
and humans may become increasingly
blurred and so yeah and Heidegger spoke
about this actually he spoke about
technology kind of like affecting us as
well as us affecting technology but I
quite like this blurring relationship
between asan technology so um in the
context of machine lab I mean how do you
envision the future of human machine
relationships and and what do you think
are the implications for our
understanding of love and human
flourishing
yeah I take a sort of strong position in
the paper at least of saying that if
possible
we might want to steer clear of
developing relationships
with machines
um
and so like not having machines that
simulate affect or simulate
relationships with us and I think
probably it's just a personal bias like
it kind of creeps me out a little bit
and I can admit that to think of like
starting to have like an attachment
relationship with a machine Learning
System that you know maybe engineered
for some purpose that isn't really
aligned with me
um so I know there's you know something
called like replica where you can go and
have you know some kind of relationship
with machine I think they recently
changed kind of how they're thinking
about it but at some point it was kind
of like you almost would have like a
kind of like a virtual girlfriend kind
of experience and I think that was and
there's like a capitalistic kind of
incentive behind it
um which is kind of you know feels like
it just muddies the waters a lot
um and in some ways
I'm conflicted because it could be
beneficial to the the most lonely of us
to have that kind of the comfort of that
kind of relationship
and I kind of worry about the kind of
character traits that it will
accentuate within us that already a lot
of our technology is kind of
I think to our detriments inclining us
towards comfort
and so you know it's easier to
order a meal through doordash than it is
to kind of go out and have a human
interaction with somebody go to an
actual restaurant
it's easier kind of veg out and watch
Netflix than to go to a movie theater
and I'm not that these other experiences
are necessarily better but there's
something about like just like the every
step along the way we're finding drawn
into comfort
and I think we've lose somehow and that
that
calculus and if there's a lot of comfort
that comes from us interacting with
an agent that's been perfectly
engineered to
just
always be there for us
I wonder if that will
harm our ability to to connect with real
humans and what at scale that would mean
for society and maybe it's fine
um but I guess I
I guess like there's kind of this
precautionary principle thing that I
think often
I just wonder yeah where that would lead
us and maybe if we're not careful we get
there too quickly without really
thinking about what that would do to us
yeah I mean doordash is a great example
of reintologization
um even remote what remote working is a
great example of re-antologization
because at the beginning I thought this
is brilliant I'm just working from home
all the time you know uh in the evenings
I've got more time to work on the
YouTube channel but I'm not I don't I
don't really
um see any other people anymore and and
my life has been you know truncated at a
cellular level I mean I I feel like my
life has shrunk infinitely over the last
few years but I wanted to talk about
um you know popular culture a little bit
and how they represent AIS so
um in in popular culture we've seen
aspects of AI human interaction through
movies like you know Gatica her um
Spielberg's Ai and interstellars tars
you know that that robot and
Interstellar and um they each presented
different visions of loving AI or the
importance of an emotional intelligence
in in Ai and how do you think your
concept of machine lover lines or
differs from these portrayals I mean in
what way does your work address
um you know the concerns such as the for
AI to possess a heart or to avoid these
paternalistic controls over humans as
Illustrated in movies like iRobot
yeah I think the point I came at was
that
I am most concerned with
the kind of large-scale machine learning
systems that already are influencing us
a lot and that might not need for an AI
to explicitly relate to us
and so like systems like like Facebook
or Twitter or YouTube where
part of the thing is just humans
interacting so humans are acting in the
system and where AI plays a role is
somehow in shaping our experience from
the Shadows so it's already kind of
there and it's shaping things
but shaping things in a way that really
isn't aligned with our you know
well-being and I'm sure there are people
working to you know to make improvements
to these systems because I think some of
the problems with engagement are well
known
but it'd be great if there was something
that from
you know from in the background was
helping to shape your experience but in
a way you wanted it to be shaped and an
appealing more to yeah your long-term
kind of aspirations
and
kind of like helping you explore so kind
of like helping you navigate through
like YouTube there's so many different
niches you could get interested in so
many educational things so many
beautiful artistic Creations that you
could get interested in
and
yeah could a system help you to do that
and so I try to skirt maybe I try to
skirt the issue of whether the agent
should relate to you in like a direct
way I think I would want that probably
less of that than maybe other people
would but still it should have emotional
intelligence it should still understand
things about you
um and ideally not from the perspective
of trying to manipulate you but in
trying to actually support your autonomy
because right now
um in subtle ways and not so subtle ways
our autonomy is is constantly a little
bit under attack
and
it's hard to really you know feel that
but but one example that's what's
interesting to me is
um
like my cell phone is is right beside me
and it's something that I
check every morning when I get up
and
it's hard for me just to really piece
together like on a visceral level
yeah that there's this
um War for my attention that's going on
you know he needed to throw these apps
and all the different kind of incentives
that are under the app inventors and
really like it it is kind of like
there's like a there's like a danger
not like to my life necessarily but to
my time and my autonomy by you know the
more I spend time browsing Twitter and
looking for these little likes or
whatever or new followers
um
it is it is kind of like an attack on my
autonomy and it's it's not like
malevolent it's not that someone I think
behind the scenes is saying like I
really want to undermine Joel's autonomy
but it's just through everyone following
the incentives that they're given that's
kind of the result that we find
ourselves Within
yeah exactly I mean and like an another
angle to to the question I suppose as
well is because I was talking about the
tars robot in interstellar
um it has agentiveness it has a
personality and you've probably seen
that uh less romance I think I haven't
seen I haven't seen that particular one
unfortunately oh oh it's okay so there's
this friendly robot that that works
around and apparently I think it has to
be nice to you 90 of the time because
that that's what makes humans um
happiest or whatever but but you know I
guess part of the point I'm making is is
this this um dichotomy between
macroscopic collective intelligence as
being this kind of mesh of of
um agents
which causal pressures and acting and so
on and
um a robot that you anthropomorphize
that has a personality that has agency
and that that you can address and
there's there's an article on less wrong
called simulators which actually talks
of language models as being a
superposition of agents and of course
that makes it have more friction with
the alignment narrative because agents
have goals and beliefs and so on but but
then if they're agents then then we kind
of anthropomorphize them and when you
anthropomorphize something that you're
because you're talking about if it's
just a phone that's one thing but if if
it's actually
um something that ianthropomorphize an
agent that has goals beliefs theory of
mind and so on that's far more likely to
affect me and my mental state because
that because that's my interface
yeah
yeah anthropomorphize is a
interesting word
and I think I have mixed feelings about
it
um
I think that the dangers of it of
anthropomorphizing something
um like like a robot that it's designed
to have a personality
is that
if you forget
the way in which the incentives of the
designer don't align with your own and
and really what the agent is then
it does seem like you can get into kind
of weird situations so I guess like I'm
a little paranoid about that that if an
agent's designed you know by some
privacy company
is it really going to be you know
friendly companion to you or is it going
to be kind of like also trying to sell
you things on the side
um and I think yeah yeah
well there was an example from um Stuart
Russell on uh Sam Harris podcast with um
Gary Marcus and he said that the cost
now you could that they could they could
implant an agent into your Facebook or
into your phone and it could be
developing a relationship with you over
over weeks and after week four because
remember what's the cost of just having
a chatbot running for four weeks it's
not like an advert where they've got to
try and hook you in 30 seconds after
four weeks when you've developed trust
in this agent oh do you want to buy
something
yeah right
yeah that game could be infinitely long
I guess and
and I feel I feel mixed things about it
because I think like the technologist in
me would say like be really interesting
to interact with all these different
agents and it can be fun and enlivening
and you know it could be the different
experiences
um
but I think the the kind of the more
worried part of me is I just don't know
the implications of that are for society
and I guess I'm just worried about
things going off the rails like it seems
like things are already going off the
rails a little bit and could we just
slow down a little and like not create a
new class of entities that's gonna you
know impact our psychology and even new
new ways
um so maybe I'm I'm a little bit of uh
I'm a little bit conservative in that
way but
I also
yeah I just don't know where this leads
so I was going to ask you how you think
machine love can be designed and
deployed in a way that minimizes you
know societal impacts and and avoids the
you know we've been speaking about the
pitfalls of Monolithic machine learning
implementations we want to have a
pluralistic society so um you know there
are risks of Rapid large-scale adoption
of ml systems and we should think about
how we can deploy this to prioritize
multiple culturally diverse
implementations allowing user choice and
customization you know we're talking
about the risk of paternalism and and so
on
um so you know incorporating principles
of uncertainty and moral philosophy
um that that seems like a very difficult
thing and and and then it it my mind
goes to this dichotomy we've always had
the machine learning which is designing
something versus letting it emerge and
I'm not sure whether you would think
that we should let it emerge
I think that
it is a really hard problem
and when it's worth thinking about
really hard
and
I think all that I have to offer like
potential directions that that could
help
and I'm not sure which of them or maybe
all of them you know need to be done in
concert but
one interesting
aspect is
where capitalism works and where it
doesn't work
and one kind of obstacle to capitalism
working is where there's a lack of
competition
so for example
if you have like a Facebook YouTube or
Twitter
the recommendation engine is hidden from
you and there's no competition really
among like
recommendations engines that are going
to serve you better necessarily because
no one can compete in that it's kind of
it's like a it's a mode that they
control they have a network effect it's
hard for someone to up off
to create a new Facebook or something
under YouTube and
you know maybe we have to rethink
somewhat about
when something is is almost like a new
Commons you know like like a Facebook a
YouTube or like almost like everyone has
to interact with that thing at some
level
um
do we rethink how we
what control a person has over like
their own feed their own the content
that's being pushed to them could they
could we create a place where there is
competition
four new recommendation engines or
whatever Within These systems so that
there is a race ideally to the top
instead of to just things that are going
towards engagement
um and that would kind of speak towards
pluralism that you would want a lot of
different implementations
of things like machine laws so yeah like
you said like not a single monolithic
implementation
and
you could imagine
even putting limits on like how many
people could share the same model or
something that'd be a little bit
artificial
um
yeah yeah I mean because it gets it gets
to this trade-off between autonomy and
paternalism because as you say on the
autonomy side one interesting approach
that you spoke to is allowing people to
choose their own recommendation
algorithms and you could argue one on
Facebook and YouTube the way the
algorithm works is
um it it it encourages freedom to choose
Tick Tock even more so it it's
it it knows exactly what you want but
that's actually not what you want what
you want is not what you want and and
even even when even when the learning
rate is lower on Facebook it's still not
what you want there's conspiracy there
is and all sorts of stuff so so then you
you so that that's the bottom-up
emergence so uh the people at Facebook
they're not malicious people they didn't
they didn't design this to happen but it
emerged and and then and then you can
think about well we can have top-down
government
um uh regulatory pressures like saying
oh this kind of thing isn't allowed this
kind of thing isn't allowed and
presumably there needs to be an
interplay between the two but the
interesting thing though is is that you
can't really precisely it's like we were
saying with subjective experience you
can't precisely specify what kind of
Dynamics are acceptable because it's not
it's not really codable in in a rule set
and I suppose that's kind of what you
deal with in in alignment anyway
yeah I mean it does seem like we're
getting towards a place where
instruction following models are able to
abide by some nuance
and
maybe it would be possible in the future
for you to tell your recommendation
engine from like a high level the kinds
of things you want what do you want to
accomplish and maybe keep giving
instructions on how you want it to
behave
and so we might be entering a time where
more is possible in terms of
not just having the the smoothest ux you
know like with Tick Tock you just kind
of swipe and whatever and it'll get you
the things you want but there aren't
really the things you need
um but maybe you could imagine giving
instructions to tick tock giving voice
instructions or something saying like um
yeah I can get really addicted to these
uh these you know these five second
Comedy clips but I'm really actually
interested in learning more about you
know psychology Tick Tock or something
and maybe there are a lot of wholesome
things there potentially I'm not really
a heavy Tick Tock user
um but just don't use it oh yeah I think
maybe maybe some wise thing and kind of
keeping yourself from you know the thing
that's closest to the brain stem
um but yeah yeah but maybe like you know
alignment research or just in general
machine learning progress will enable us
to do more nuanced things that are more
personalized to you but personalized to
you not on the level of just kind of
Base based once but really you know on
the level of aspirations or things like
that
yeah that that's so true and I think
there are differences between the social
network platforms and a lot of it is to
do with the learning rate and
um how how much it it appeals to your
monkey brain because for example on on
YouTube it really does give me that's
the thing it's almost like we have a
hierarchy of um you know you spoke about
the hierarchy of needs but we we have
something a bit like that in terms of
how we consume information and when you
turn the learning rate to uh too high
like on Tick Tock it will just kind of
appeal to your
um most visceral kind of monkey brain
urges and you'll just get lots of stuff
there that would just be you you know
it's bad for you and on YouTube it's
showing me lots of videos of maths and
philosophy and Science and all the
things that I actually want to look at
so it's not like it's not possible to
design an algorithm which is enriching
and um yeah so that's something
interesting to think about but I just
wanted to ask you a little bit about
what your philosophical influences was
because you know obviously this is a
this is a fascinating paper that you've
written and maybe you can speak a little
bit about what motivated it but are
there any historical influences that
kind of shaped your thoughts on this
topic
yeah
I think for whatever reason and maybe
this is true for a lot of researchers
I'm drawn to the topics that are
relevant to me on some level personally
um and
so
I'm the kind of person that
um
does sometimes look for like the formal
explanation of something so maybe for
some people you know love is really
intuitive and I think for me like the
skills of Love is are confusing like
like how you can actually be there for
someone in a way that's not
um
gonna hurt their autonomy but is
actually helping them to be who they
want to be
um and like the difference between that
kind of impulse and kind of the the
limerence kind of crush kind of
um falling in love feeling
and
it's um it's just like a personal point
of view it's just kind of interesting to
think about that and I think in terms of
like influences
I think it was kind of diving into the
the Psychotherapy literature at some
point I I almost
um I did sign up for like a therapist
master's degree
um just exploring becoming a therapist
because just found it really fascinating
like what is it we're up to as humans
like I don't I don't know it's there's
no it seemed like really hard to pin
down and there's so many different
so I think I have like a Meandering you
know trail of like different
philosophical things I've I've dived
into as a dilaton like to read about
um like actually existentialism versus
um you know other sorts of philosophies
and just feeling like
I don't
from from within that frame it makes
sense of that particular view but then
it cross frames it just seems like
almost like we just get to choose or
something and it's just something
about how hard it is to pin down like
from like a machine learning point of
view like what how could a machine
learning algorithm optimize for
something that helps you
um it just seemed really really really
unclear
and it kind of does blossom out of some
of the you know the work I did in the
past about you know quite greatness
cannot be planned
um but yeah just
I think over overarchingly is something
like
how do we
how do we kind of like grow and flourish
and innovate but also stay safe those
are the I think the two things I've been
trying to square that I still don't know
how to square
really interesting I mean um a lot of
this comes back to the lenses that we
use and you were speaking to many of the
different lenses that you've put on in
the past and
this actually gets me on to a really
interesting question about
um you know I guess like being rational
and abstraction and different models to
to understand things so game theory is
an interesting example that was invented
by um Von Neumann in the 20th century
and it was controversially used by Ayan
Rand and and later in economics and so
on and um we know that humans are not
rational agents right although you might
want to comment on on that approach of
modeling them but you mentioned um how
such a framework would render irrational
Behavior like addiction axiomatically
impossible and then you spoke to the
approach in Psychology and psychology is
focused on the ways that human develop
humans develop over time cognitively
emotionally morally and socially but
even the psychology approach fails the
bitter lesson test and what you know
about invoking rich Saturn where he
talks about hand designed abstractions
um so yeah it imputes yet more reductive
human abstractions into the model you
know like the kind of psychology
abstractions that were like in Maslow's
hierarchy of needs and so so even the
hierarchy of needs could just be viewed
as a different type of of lens to
analyze Behavior rather than a game
theory predictive model
um so given the numerous counter
examples that that exists like you know
parents for example they sacrificed
their own needs for their children's
education
um so I guess the question is coming
back to your um you know seminal
greatness can't be planned book it feels
like the lens of the model itself always
gets in the way like what do you think
that's a a challenging question I'm
trying to think about how to think about
it
so if I understand correctly you're
saying like there's this kind of the
game theory lens where almost like
selfishness is kind of the winning
strategy whereas
what we know from like parents is kind
of like there's this altruistic
sacrifice that they often give
yes so so
um with Game Theory I suppose I mean
Ayan Rand made the assumption that we
are all self-interested agents but you
don't necessarily need to have that
assumption in a game theory um uh model
but in in the game theoretical model you
it's it's a very high resolution model
when you model actors and their
affordances and you kind of play it out
through simulation but
um
Psychology and Neuroscience for the last
20 years has developed these very
um kind of like low Fidelity
abstractions mostly just for
computational tractability more than
anything else so neuroscientists would
create these multi-arm Bandit models and
rather than modeling raw sensory data
they would model you know like my social
affect and my color perception and and
all of these like abstract Concepts and
in a way this is the same thing so we're
saying here's the psychology literature
here's Maslow's hierarchy of needs here
are five abstractions that they're a
little bit brittle but they work quite
well and I'm I'm now going to impute
those abstractions into my model the
same way we used to do feature
Engineering in in you know 20 years ago
in machine learning so I guess I'm just
saying that that that that lens in in a
way obscures the deeper reality
yeah
I think I would approach it maybe from
two separate directions
um One Direction is that
although the the lens of the model is
going to get in the way
it is
working with the better lesson like a
language model is at least in the sense
that it is
learning from massive amounts of data
that include data about The Human
Experience
and in theory
you could imagine it eventually coming
up with being language models being used
to come up with more holistic
or more
closer to the metal explanations of
Psychology by analyzing for example just
biographies at scale or diaries at scale
um
there could be some way where it you
know is able to come much more granular
theories of what it means to flourish I
mean I'm not really sure about that but
that's like you know one way of looking
at it
and I think one challenge to the kind of
bitter lens
Paradigm release from this is that the
better lens is kind of about like you
can learn from a lot of data but to what
end
um you know I think it's like it's not
really talking about like the you know
the the lens of like what we should be
doing
um and from that I would start from the
other side it's kind of like the
evolutionary side um so I used to you
know I still work with evolutionary
algorithms but that's kind of like where
I kind of um came up in the machine
learning community and so when you're
studying Evolution algorithms you often
think a lot about biological evolution
and
um that we like another layer of
complexity is like what it is that we
you know should be optimizing for
um
is kind of entangled with what what we
were optimized for and arguably that
something like you know the fitness of
our
our genes and that does cut through the
kind of the iron ran kind of thing where
actually like it's
selfish to be cooperative
um
you know through lenses like caring for
your children because caring for your
genes and maybe there was some group
level selection where we learned to be
you know collaborative
um to
uh for the best of our species but I
think like one gnarly kind of confusing
bit is
we are in the position of transcending
evolution
like we don't like what evolution wants
for us is necessarily the best thing
Evolution doesn't want for us to you
know the flourish and be happy once for
us to to pass on our genes and it uses
happiness and flourishing and sort of
the incentive to push us along
and so you know we get to decide
somewhat and this kind of Tangled Loop
you know we get to decide what it is we
want to optimize for so I think there's
you know always going to be I think like
this human the human lens on what we
want to use this data This Bitter listen
better lesson kind of driven engine to
do
and partly we can maybe use those tools
the language models to understand
better you know what what the cause and
effect is you know for us to to flourish
but maybe part of this also we we have
to just really reason through what we
think is best for us individually and US
collectively
and there may be no way to you know get
around just that we we have to decide as
humans like what we want and I don't
know that I have like a you know a ton
of insight there
yeah I mean it's so interesting I mean
um just just for the listeners benefit
as well so um Joel has done loads and
loads of work and things like um
open-endedness Quality diversity
evolutionary algorithms and
um there's this really interesting idea
that even though Evolution you can think
of it and by the way Kenneth and Joel
have said that we don't really
understand Natural Evolution but very
well but um you can think of evolution
as being almost an infinitude of of
niches and Specialties and and it's just
this open-ended process but you were
just saying that in a sense there's a
dichotomy between the The Meta objective
uh which what might even be intelligible
and verbalizable which is you know the
the propagation of our DNA versus this
Panna play of of niches which is why in
in many of Joel's algorithms that the
idea in an open-ended system is is
almost to have a pan a play of of
objectives to accumulate information
continuously but but when you look at us
there's this weird separation isn't
there between my dopamine system and and
I actually have autonomy I can choose
not to have children and I can wirehead
myself and I can I can basically do
anything I want because there's there's
only a very kind of like weird resonance
between my my goals and the goals of of
the meta optimizer
yeah I've often been interested in
interested in the AI alignment kind of
Paradigm and
there is some way where
we are poorly aligned to like the
Evolution's goals for us and it's
beautiful that we are because
um if we were in chain to just maximize
you know reproductive Fitness that'd be
sort of
um a hellish World probably
um so it's really interesting yeah that
we
we do have this pressure still this this
the heritage of of evolution within us
that can be for good or for bad and
sometimes you know like there are lots
of beautiful Parts about human
connection and care and and things that
we can do for each other and they're
like all off awful impulses within us
you know where genocide is still not
outside the distribution of behaviors
that that humans enact even in this day
um and so I think there's a way where we
do want to continue to transcend the you
know the really problematic parts of our
nature or engineer a world where they're
less apt to emerge and One Direction
there is you know in an idealized Vision
that as we become less resource
constrained where each of us has access
to at least the the tools we need to
survive that maybe some of these
urges
um for
uh
dominance or or you know the in-group
versus the app Group would kind of
evaporate
although as you alluded to earlier
um
we also struggle with that a lot of our
Notions of status and how well we're
doing a relative and that there's some
tragedy where we all can become material
material materially more wealthy uh just
better well off collectively and yet
um not be any happier for it because
we're kind of stuck in this hedonic Loop
and you know there are ways to kind of
maybe get off that hedonic Loop a little
bit you know things are silliest
gratitude journals and stuff like that
and maybe more deeper things
um to remind ourselves like just there
is the relative but there's the absolute
like we are we are much better off than
we used to be in in very real terms and
I'm grateful for that and I don't
remember to be grateful enough
um
so it is a weird position that we're in
and
um yeah I'm not sure what to makeup
anyway um we should we should probably
wrap this up actually yeah yeah I think
this has been a marathon we've been
going for two hours um anyway Dr Joel
lemon has been an honor and a privilege
to have you on thank you thank you so
much for joining us yeah it's been great
to be here this has been a lot of fun
thank you so so much for having me I
really hope you enjoyed that
conversation with Joel lemon he
concluded in his paper that the
potential for machine learning to
support human flourishing and growth
presents both a compelling opportunity
and a complex challenge the paper
proposed a nascent positive vision for
the future of machine learning
advocating for a more profound
integration of humanistic Knowledge from
diverse Fields such as philosophy
positive psychology and Psychotherapy by
Bridging the Gap between machine
learning formalisms and
interdisciplinary understandings of
human flourishing he said that we can
develop systems that genuinely enhance
our well-being and Empower our
aspirations
now he said that future
interdisciplinary work is essential to
address the limitations and critiques of
this approach which relies on language
model simulations of humans rather than
actual human studies and additionally
exploring alternative Frameworks of
machine love in their practical
algorithmic implementations can draw
inspiration from various
psychotherapeutic theories philosophies
of life and developing psychological
perspectives
furthermore leveraging advances in
machine learning can contribute
significantly to the realization of
machine love integrating beneficial
expertise from folks such as
psychologists counselors or coaches
looking at language model inferences and
even improving them through some of the
recent developments such as rlhf but now
we need to consider how can we
effectively validate the current
approaches generalization through
interactions with real human subjects
providing empirical evidence for its
viability in promoting human flourishing
which alternative Frameworks of machine
love can be identified and how can we
develop practical algorithmic
implementations that incorporate these
diverse perspectives and finally how can
the interdisciplinary synthesis of
machine learning and humanistic
knowledge be Advanced to better address
the challenges of supporting human
aspirations particularly in the light of
the ever-changing long-term and nuanced
nature of these aspirations
by addressing these questions and
fostering interdisciplinary
collaboration we can strive towards a
world where machine learning truly
empowers human growth and flourishing
transforming the way that we harness
technology for social benefit
anyway I really hope you enjoyed this
show please join our Discord Community
or support us on patreon subscribe on
YouTube and rate US on your podcasting
app I really appreciate you joining us
today cheers